we are going places we're not going to
wait on anybody we're not gonna sit
there and wait on anyone to be in a
perfect mood to want to go out and run
with us all we know is life happens to
all of us not every day is an easy day
not every day is a simplest day to go
through some people have challenges with
their families their kids all this other
stuff but no matter what you things your
biggest problem no matter what meetings
the biggest problem you and I have the
opportunity we have all our senses you
can see you can smell you can taste you
can touch you can hear you have all your
senses you can walk and we can learn
what you read we have the ability to get
to work and take advantage of free
enterprise system and build a lifestyle
that we want to build and the dream was
sold to me that if I go out and work
hard I can build a life that I want to
build widows start with having a
positive attitude it'll start with being
grateful it'll start with you giving
your part your best effort into
something to see what could happen if
you do that